en somme pouvait plus loin un partage
ont le coeur sur la main l'avenir
l'amour pour dessiner les chemins 1 1 de
demain 1 1 de demain
seul on va plus loin ensemble on pas
plus loin tous ces régimes au départ
tous hier lady nos voisins selon bâle
plus loin en son nom
la plus grande
[Musique]
oui
1 2
ma
cela
au coeur de notre ville 7
il éviter pour plus humaine
fraternité non plus d'humanité plus
paternité
à venir
je ne
[Musique]
je
demain
non
oh
c
que le sol et a arrêté des citoyens unis
pour la libère
au coeur empli de lincent cercle des
beaux hôtels
envie de couleurs
[Musique]
il
non
poule à
[Musique]
oh
ensemble on va plus on sent bon bah plus
long pour la libye
la nuit
[Musique]
oh
et si oui
[Musique]
oh